the agriculture and fisheries council
has secured a political agreement on
fishing opportunities for deep sea
stocks for 2015 and 2016 with the
support from an overwhelming majority of
member states the regulation will be
formally adopted at the next council in
december and into force at the start of
next year
it will ensure the sustainable
management of our fish stocks while
taking into account the
economic effects of our decisions as
well deep sea fish have often long
reproduction cycles so the ministers
were aware of the need to be careful
with quotas for those species the
decision will see a small increase in
overall catches for some stocks but
significant reductions for species close
to collapse
no fishing will be allowed for
vulnerable shark species in an effort to
ensure their protection
on agricultural matters many ministers
express concerns about plans to reduce
the common agricultural policy budget in
2015. they believe that russia's import
ban on some foods has already hit the
sector hard enough
the ministers also discussed measures to
help strengthen policies towards young
farmers to help provide a viable future
for european agriculture